a powerful leader of the field is not
usually a descriptor for a woman
oftentimes a woman is described in terms
of her excellent teaching ability and
her mentoring but that's not considered
the attribute that leads to leadership
and scientific advances I like working
with men I was raised with brothers I
have no sisters my laboratory for
example is a very consensus-driven
collaborative laboratory it is not a
traditional sort of male organized
structure and being able to appreciate
those differences and value them I think
is a very important part of the
advancement of our science that being
said I have no no hesitation in
reporting experiences of pretty
extraordinary discrimination and this
these types of discrimination events are
are benign in that they're not
intentional but they're probabilistic
that means that at every single decision
point that a woman scientist has she's a
little bit just a little bit more
vulnerable than a comparable male column
and when we look at the numbers they cry
for an explanation why is it that we
start as undergraduates now with as a
50-50 distribution of women in many of
the hard sciences and there is this
progressive attrition of women to the
high ranks
so that when we get to the tenure ranks
the university what happens to all the
women well it's easy to give
explanations about you know life's
complexities family etc etc etc that
doesn't explain it if you ask the women
that started out in the trajectory and
didn't make it even if a woman does get
tenure for example she doesn't so often
get the endowed chair that is given to
the more favored colleagues which is
oftentimes a man men with endowed chairs
have better salary support because they
have money from the endowed chair the
woman doesn't and so even at the highest
ranks it is more difficult I think for
women scientists if you love the science
and if that's what you're born to do
then don't be discouraged by any of this
just go do it somehow they'll be away
sometimes you have to learn when not to
be too much of a lady so if you have to
kick ass just go do it that's what women
are going to have to do they're going to
face that every once in a while that you
just sometimes got to be tougher than
you are it's important for institutions
to value their women let their women
know that they are valued and to put put
supports in place that allow ambitious
talented women to contribute as best
they can
you